mac rumors just came out with their new
mac rumors podcast and they had mark
german as a guest and within that
podcast he revealed a ton of details
about what we should expect from apple
in 2022 so let's go ahead and get into
those details the first topic in terms
of the apple watch was the rugged watch
he says it could potentially look like a
g-shock or a casio watch it's gonna be a
higher end more expensive model
potentially with a third larger screen
size he says that apple has recently
been testing a body temperature sensor
there is a chance that it might get
delayed now moving on to apple's ar and
vr headset and he says that this new
product is going to require a new
operating system maybe called ros and in
terms of the release date wwdc in june
makes the most sense this is gonna be
apple's biggest product in seven years
it's gonna be very expensive and it's
gonna focus on three different things
with the first one being communication
media consumption and gaming